Batman and Robin because I think I was  the perfect age for that movie when it  came out and I have a very soft spot for  it even though I know it's not as widely  beloved as the other Batman movies so I  just want to know what is the moment  from making that movie that you will  never forget that you still to this day  are very proud of  I mean I loved all my scenes with  Michael Gough Michael Gough is a dream  and I just love that man so much and so  you know just being with him was  incredible and lovely I'm trying to  think of what else I would be proud of I  mean I like it when I get to  to the like fighting scenes with uma  thurman that's fun but I'd like to do it  all over again as this woman I think it  would be much better now  [Music]  [Applause]